I don't care what Joe Rogan or anybody
says to go to Austin I'm not leaving La
but has it gone downhill like we're
driving through Eagle Rock got bad
graffiti everywhere people like roaming
the streets that's why I don't go there
where do you go just in my neighborhood
oh we're back in the day there's blood
and Crips dog what's up I never went to
Compton right and checked it out like
Venice I didn't even go there man those
are the worst kind of homeless yeah
wolves and Venice think they have talent
check me out and then you're like here's
a dollar what was that so you had been
yeah and they saw cap dancing they have
some sort of instrument that like made
out of 10 and you know I mean when you
go down there you see the guy with the
electric guitar oh yeah the rollerblades
yeah he's like the Denzel of that yes
right